خلينا نذهب الى زاويتنا الصحيه والحديث عن
اهم ما يؤثر على رائحه السائق رائحه
انت كمان
وصحته طوال الشهر الفضيل وهو القسط الكافي
من النوم الصحي اضطرابات النوم واحده من
اكثر المشكلات شيوعا في رمضان بين العمل
والافطار والقاء الاصدقاء والسهر مع
العائله والعبادات ووجبه السحور المتاخره
يضيع الكثير وتضيع من الراحه
النصيحه الذهبيه للنوم هي الالتزام بروتين
او جدول ثابت للنوم يمكن ان يساعد على
تسهيل الامور بشكل كبير ينصح خبراء بتجنب
السهر لاوقات متاخره والنوم بعد صلاه
العشاء وعند الاستيقاظ لتناول وجبه يجب ان
تكون دسمه وثقيله وطبعا لكافيين فيها يا
نادين بالمناسبه وجدت بعض الابحاث ان
تناول فاكهه الكيوي يمكن ان يساعد على
الخلود الى النوم بشكل اسرع ويحسن ايضا من
جودته مزيد حول عادات تحمينا من اضطرابات
النوم في رمضان مع لميس ابراهيم
النعاس والارهاق ضعف التركيز وانخفاض
الاداء الوظيفي كلها اعراض شائعه في نهار
رمضان وسببها الرئيسي اضطرابات النوم من
ساعات راحه قليله او متقطعه لتقليل هذه
الاضطرابات هناك عده نصائح اولها القيلوله
قبل الافطار بشرط الا تتعدى 30 دقيقه اي
قبل دخول في مرحله النوم العميق حتى لا
تؤثر على النوم ليلا ويفضل النوم بعد صلاه
العشاء لاربع ساعات قبل الاستيقاظ تناول
وجبه السحور ثم النوم لمده ساعتين
اضافيتين بعد الفجر وقبل الذهاب الى العمل
النشاط البدني في النهار يمكن ان يساعد
على النوم بسهوله اكبر اثناء الليل وافضل
الاوقات لممارسه الرياضه يكون قبل ساعه من
الافطار بشكل عام ومن اجل نوم افضل تنصح
ايضا مؤسسه النوم الوطنيه في الولايات
المتحده بابعاد الاجر الالكترونيه
كالتلفزيون والكمبيوتر والهواتف الذكيه
من غرفه النوم
[موسيقى]